the votes are in
they've all been counted no we ain't
doing no recount
the american music awards brought out
these music legends who came to the city
of angels for the last
major awards ceremony of 2020.
oh hey guys taylor swift won the night's
biggest award
artist of the year and confirmed she's
in the process of re-recording her first
six studio albums which is why she
couldn't attend the show in person
i'm actually re-recording all of my old
music in
the studio where um where we originally
recorded it so it's been amazing and i
can't wait for you to hear it
before the show megan fox and machine
gun kelly made a splash with their red
carpet debut
followed by justin bieber kicking the
night off with a self-reflected
performance
literally my house was always made of
glass
well maybe that's the price you pay for
the money and fame
at an early age the pop star staying
both
lonely and holy from his new album and
then joined
shawn mendes for a performance of their
brand new collab
monster megan the stallion and cardi b's
wap
nab the trophy for favorite song rap in
hip-hop
thank you to all all the people that
support it
the hot girl of summer herself twerked
the night away during her performance of
yeah you body good but they still want
to know where making it saucy like a
barbecue but you won't get your baby
back
see me in that dress and he feel like he
almost tasted that meg teased her ama's
performance while speaking with e.t
leading up to the big night i'm like oh
my god i can't believe
i'm performing at the amas like this is
such
a big jump for me and i just always want
to impress my hobbies like i always want
them to feel like
they went on the journey with me and
they did go on they are going on the
journey with me so i'm just so excited
to
to be in the spot that i am now because
for everybody who's been watching me
until this point like you know you know
how hard i work
and you know how passionate i am about
music and just
the fact that we've made it this far
like we need to pat all ourselves on the
back
the all-star performance lineup
continued with billy eilish
dan and shea nelly katy perry and dua
lipa
who literally took flight during her
performance of levitating from london's
royal albert hall
i'm going to be filming mine from london
so um
we're going to we're going to create
something really really special
something exciting
something very british and
yeah i i don't want to give too much
away you know i'm hopefully it'll be
like a surprise to people that's
always my aim that sex is
sex it's responsible for a lot of babies
but it was the weeknd who made these
fireworks with his outdoor performance
thank you army andy amas for this great
honor
here with us today to celebrate together
k-pop superstars bts not only won
favorite pop rock duo
or group but they have the honor of
capping off the night
with a performance of their song life
goes on
[Music]
which they teased for e.t before the
show we talked about many
themes and emotions and put all of them
into these levels taraji p henson emceed
the jam pack ceremony
and even performed a dance montage that
included tributes to prince
jay-z and savage taraji gave e.t
all the deets behind her electric
performance will you
perform it all or will you just host
well come on there
they'll come on why do you think they
called me
[Laughter]
but i'm just trying to get a hint of
what you're going to give us and how you
can
well i want i i literally want well you
know that there are covet restrictions
you know i wanted to do this huge big
opening dance number with all of these
dancers but we've been limited to the
amount of dancers
we can have due to crowbit but we're
artists
so we're going to be creative it's still
going to be a really big
shoe and um yeah it is it's going to be
big and amazing and creative and that's
the great thing about artists
you can't hold this down you can't pin
us down you can't
you will we're in the guidelines but we
are still creative
you know so